but everybody seems to be going back and
getting haircuts
what's the what's the best practice now
and what's the safety track record like
yeah so as the station reopened pretty
much every state
uh imposed guidelines for salons and
barbershops
to reopen safely and you know there's
some variants but across the board
masks should be required from the barber
as well
as the client there should be no
walk-ins there should be appointments
only so people are showing up at the
time
of their appointment and they're waiting
uh outside of the shop so there's no
more waiting inside the shop
um there should be uh disinfecting of
the barber chair all of the supplies uh
all of the tools um a lot of states are
requiring uh disposable capes
so you're not you're not using an old
cape that somebody wore this
for you that's smart yeah yeah i liked
it i like the disposable cape
um just for cleanliness in general
yeah absolutely just make it out of
paper toss it afterwards yeah
talk just just toss it are they are
people reconfiguring these to put in
plastic
between the stations or is that like
overkill i've seen that
i've seen that um not it's not like
across the board but i've seen some
shots experimenting with that
which the plastic buffer is always
because like
the germs can go over the plastic yeah
that one doesn't make sense to me
like if you're in a confined space
it really is the density of the space
and then the mask wearing
so people just need to be vigilant about
on both sides wearing masks and then the
face shield
yeah is like an extra protection for
dentists and people who have to do this
10 times a day
yeah and that seems to work right that
that's that that works i mean first of
all
barbers are probably one of the only
types of professionals who are actually
trained on this
prior to they they really to get their
license
they have to study uh
you know just how to disinfect materials
how to not you know spread disease like
that that's all part of their
their education anyway now you have this
this covert situation
and like they're they're one of the best
prepared types of professionals in my
opinion to handle this versus like you
know a waiter
who just could be anybody um so barbers
have to be licensed
according to you know state law um
and and in terms of like what we're
seeing like like you said there have
been
uh uh reports of um
spread you know inside i think it was a
salon actually but interestingly in that
salon they all wore mass and no
no clients were infected so i mean it it
goes
there were like hundreds of custom forms
so we're also showing you like the power
of actually where if everybody wears a
mask and if the procedures
are followed that's a very interesting
point
if people just were if we just studied
barber shops
which have you know five chairs
and 10 customers for each chair you got
50 people coming in and out a day
with five barbers and you know uh
probably a reception area so you're
talking about
you know six stationary people and 50
people coming out you could just use
that as your testing and tracing
uh and then eventually people could test
when they get to the barber shop
i don't know if you've seen that
starting yet but i predict that's going
to become the big win
is just come to the barber shop and get
tested and we'll throw in the 15
test yeah government should really be
working with with barber shops
um because they're really uh you know
there's hubs of the community
and people are going to continue getting
aircrafts you know as long as
as long as they can and had barbershops
been a vector of spread like they'd be
shut down immediately like we would have
heard about it
and so we know that's not happening